hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that a lot of you have
recommended
to me already i've decided to check it
out and it really is quite the game it's
been played in the vergany cup
uh between uh german women's
international master ahmadi mitch and
uh dutch uh dutch international master
max
varmardam and it's just the kind of game
we need to properly uh start 2021 with
so without further ado
let's check it out uh as uh and opens
with
have e5 by max knight to f3 knight to c6
uh sorry about that uh and d4 now
so striking in the center just a normal
scotch here we have e
captures and knight captures and knight
captures on d5 and here
bishop to c5 attacking the knights twice
and here
knight to b3 attacking the bishop on c5
now if you remember we
uh we covered this position many times
but it's also the
position from the one of the most famous
games ever played
between xqc and moist critical also
known as charlie white where
uh the game continued c3 queen to f6
and now uh uh knight captures on c6 and
queen captures on f2 checkmate
i don't know if you've seen that game
but it was uh you know a lot of us about
that game
you know with the one with all the
throbbing so bishop to c5 and
knight back to b3 attacking the bishop
on c5 bishop back to b6
and knight to c3 so this has all been
played before and this is all very
standard theory
uh knight f6 uh developing knight
preparing the castle and the queen to e2
now
uh also the defending the for pawn twice
preparing to develop the dark square
bishop also castling queen side will be
an option
castle's king side and here bishop to
e3s planned challenging the dark square
bishop on b6
and here max just launches forward with
d5 and it makes sense the white king is
still in the center of the board so why
not
here we have queen side castles now not
allowing the pawn to capture anything
since the queen is still on d8
and here we have d4 attacking both
knight and
bishop and again this has all been
played before nothing new happening here
uh the most common move in this position
is bishop to g5
uh also uh this was played there is a
very famous game
uh anand versus laura fresney in the
aliens memorial in 2013 in saint
petersburg
uh where anand won a very nice game but
here uh
not bishop to g5 but ryder king to b1
and king to b1 is a new move in the
position
so already as of move 10 we have a
completely new game
and uh again of course both pieces are
off limits the queen is still on d8 and
here
max just starts uh going after the white
king so a4 he wants to push that
pawn all the way uh and now knight to b5
and this is now very tricky because uh
if a4 just knight captures so nothing to
worry about there the pawn is attacked
four times so there's no way to defend
it and here
something really awesome happens here
max plays d
captures an e3 he captures that pawn and
now offers a full queen
so let's just hit print screen here we
might even use this as a thumbnail
and if you don't capture the queen
there's really not much to play you're
down a piece so you have to capture the
queen
uh and captures the queen and now rook
captures on the e8 and
now the simple f3 so a queen for a
a piece and a rook and how do you how do
you evaluate this well
white should definitely be better but
it's always unpleasant especially with
the past pawn already on e3
and the queen has to block it so it's
not not very pleasant but let's see how
the game continues
bishop to e6 max continues development
and now knights to c1 we have
knights to d7 shifting the knight over
to the center of the board and now
queen to e1 making room for the bishop
we have
knight d to e5 centralizing the knight
and now
bishop to a2 and here now as the c4
square is guarded by the knight
just bishop the c4 sorry knights to c4
uh now an excellent square for the
knight and it
offers a white to capture that knight
and it is in fact
good to capture the knight as this light
square bishop is really doing nothing
so here and captures we have captures by
bishop and
now knight uh sorry knights the c3 now
this knight is coming to d1 and from d1
this knight will be attacking the e3
pawn and it's not all that clear how
black will defend the e3 pawn and once
the e3 pawn falls
uh it's basically just uh a winning
position for white so here
rook to d2 an excellent rook lift and
well
once you double up here it's going to be
a very unpleasant position for white so
here
in the immediate knight to d1 it is the
only good move for white in the position
you have to eliminate that e3 pawn and
there's uh
there simply is no better plan for white
than this but here
uh max finds a very interesting idea on
how to continue the game
with tension uh rook captures on d1 he
eliminates one of the attackers of the
e3 pawn
and now the e3 pawn will survive even
though at the price of an exchange so
queen captures on d1
and now rook to d8 pushing back the
queen and now
knight to d3 blocking and here h6
just making some breeding room for the
king so you don't have to worry about
those back rank
mating ideas uh and here queen to c1
unpinning and also
uh maybe putting pressure on the bishop
under e3 pawn maybe
maybe you maybe even white can give up
the exchange just to get rid of that
and then try to play this position queen
and knight versus uh
bishop knight and the rook but here we
have
knight to b4 and this is a very
ambitious try by max here you can
uh you can even play the very forcing
rook captures on d3
point being that after c captures and
the bishop captures with czech
king to a1 now knight to d4 ensures
black a draw so you you could just play
it out like this for example queen c3
knight to c2 check king has to go back
you're gonna go knight to b
for king has to go back you can't go to
c1 because knight captures an a2 check
wins the queen
uh so you have to go back and then we
just get a nice repetition
uh so you could actually force a draw
here but
max obviously wants more he he goes
knight to b4
now there's a triple attack on the
knight on d3 and now
knight captures on b4 we have a captures
on b4 and
rook to d1 here ann says that uh she's
very much comfortable playing a queen
against the bishop pair
uh not never a good idea as th there is
nothing
more fierce interest than a bishop pair
that is fully operational
so rook captures on d1 queen captures
and now
even e2 attacking the queen queen has to
go to e1
and now bishop to e3 and now we have
this position that is really
uh the engines give it as better for
white but it's
so uncomfortable playing it for white
because uh the pass pawn is protected
and you can never remove the queen from
e1
once the queen moves from e1 let's say
you play something like queen captures
on b4
just bishop f2 you guard the queening
square and that's it black wins
uh there are no tricks there there's
nothing here for white
so white really has to figure out how to
keep that queen into the game after this
bishop to e3
uh idea now there is uh one move here
that seems particularly strong
and that is f4 f4 is just very nice
because you cannot capture
uh once you capture on f4 you no longer
have the option of playing bishop to f2
if the queen moves and now the queen can
capture
and now it's actually a a much better
position for white for example bishop
goes back
you have to defend it uh there's uh
not not much for black to do here now
and you've managed to clear one of the
very important pawns here
uh and also instead of uh something like
this you could also play bishop captures
on h2
but just queen back to e1 of course
you're not going to allow bishop to g3
and then you're going to start pushing
those pawns get the king into the game
and so on
so here instead after bishop to e3 with
a3 by n
and now comes uh c5 not allowing this
pawn to be moved from b4 and of course
white can never capture twice on b4 so a
capture c
captures and queen captures is not
possible just bishop to f2 will be
guarding the queening square
uh and here g3 uh just improving
the the position a little bit for white
uh we have bishop to d4
and now king to a1 so here again a very
tricky position
uh it's unclear how white should proceed
and it's not very clear
how black should proceed definitely you
should bring your king into the game and
try
to get the king somehow involved but
that's a lot of pawns here and also the
queen is still on the board so you have
to be very careful
uh so here uh we have b5 by black uh
and c3 now attacking the the bishop here
we have captures captures and now
bishop back to e3 king to b2 and
now bishop to b3 and now uh it's
again how how do you improve the
position here we have h4
king to f8 now max starts bringing the
king into the game
king to b3 king to e7 we have king to b4
uh and bishop the c for now uh we have
king back to a3 and now king to e6
king back to b2 and now bishop back to
d3
so black still figuring out how to how
to continue here we have king to b3
and now g6 and i forgot to mention here
this is actually an over the board game
not
not an online game uh king to b4 and
bishop back to c4 some some repeating of
the position here
king a3 king back to e7 king to b2
and now king to e6 so it seems that both
players are content with a draw
but of course uh there's still
much moves to be to be made king to c2
uh we have king to e5 and
king back to b2 we have bishop back to
d3 king b3 and now
f6 a nice spawn move to prevent any
repetition of moves
uh and here uh again it's a very very
interesting position
white again has this beautiful
breakthrough of f4 with
check and this is uh super tricky
because now you either push the king
back and then you've taken all of these
squares away from the black king and
you will have it much easier at
keeping keeping the draw and of course
if king captures then it's
just a force to draw because of queen to
h1 check
the pawns prevent the king from going to
the dark squares the queen controls this
diagonal so your only
option is uh king to f5 and now queen h3
check
only move his king back to e4 and now
you just repeat check check check your
check and it's a force to draw
so uh this was the option here this f4
uh
twice already in the position but here
we have uh king to b4
instead and now uh black gets the upper
hand because of the much more active
king
and the bishop the c4 move now with
bishop to c4 being played
it no longer applies for example if f4
king captures you will have the d3
square available to your king
uh as now the bishop has moved so king
back to a3
g5 now by black we have captures
captures uh
and now comes king to b2 with bishop
back to d3
and now king back to b3 bishop to c for
check king to c2
and king to d6 now we have king to b2
and now bishop back to d3 king to b3
and now king to c6 we have king to a3
now king to b6 and now king back to b3
and now bishop back to c5 we have king
to b2
white just has to repeat moves there is
nothing to attempt here
the queen can never move otherwise we
said bishop f2 is just crushing
so king to c6 and now king to b3
white can be now very very happy with
the draw bishop back to e3 and now
king to a3 now we have king to d6 king
to b3
king to e5 and now king to b2 uh and
here
just g4 uh or
offering a pawn here to to to weaken
this pawn in the center so here white
goes f4
check instead and now again if you
capture here
on on e4 it's not even a draw anymore
now white actually wins the game because
of queen to h1
check you're gonna lose the bishop on d3
your only move is king f5 and now queen
to d5 check wins the bishop
and not only does it win the bishop but
it also does so with
check so you can just easily pick up the
e2 pawn so you have to be very very
careful here
after this f4 move this is this pawn is
not free for grabs so king back to e6 by
max
and now king back to b3 king d6 we have
king to b2
king to c6 and now king to b3 so a lot
of
moving around with the king king to b6
now
king the a3 and now king the c5 with
king to b3 and king to d6
king to b2 and now king to e6 we have
king to b3
and now bishop to c5
we have king back to b2 and now bishop
back to b6
king to b3 and now f5 by black and of
course
white says okay i'm very happy with this
i'm gonna grab more space here
and now uh white definitely improved the
the position as now white has a past
pawn
and now black also needs to be very
careful so bishop back to c5 king to b2
and now king to d5 by pushing the pawn
to e5 the d5 square has been weakened
and now the black king
can maybe somehow wiggle his way into
the game but it's still going to be very
tricky with the queen in the game
so queen to h1 with check we have king
to c4 and here
uh white needs to go back for example
queen to e1
and black has no way of pushing this as
long as
white keeps an eye on the f2 square
there's nothing you can do here
but uh here ann played something else
instead of e1 and
and played the ambitious e6 now she also
wants to start pushing her
uh past pawn and it doesn't seem like
black can do anything here
uh because if you go for the media the
bishop to f2
here uh then just e7 you don't really
care because if black gets a queen
white will just capture it captures
captures and now black or
white also gets a queen and now you no
longer have to worry about black's past
pawn
so instead of this uh after this queen
to h1
after this e6 move of course max did not
go for bishop to f2
he played something else but it's a very
tricky idea so feel free to pause the
video and
win this game for max while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
devious idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
bishop e4 uh it comes with an attack on
the queen
and now what can you do here with the
queen uh well
uh let's try a quinta e1 which is what
was played in the game and it does make
sense because you also want to keep an
eye on the f2
uh square but here comes the problem
king the e2
and this is this is now very very
problematic
as now bishop to e3 and bishop to d2 are
coming and you will very successfully
push the queen out of the way
and also e7 now does not help you
because the bishop covers that square so
there's no there's no tactic here for
white that saves her
so here queen the b1 check was played
king to e3 but now
queen to g1 with check but just king to
f3 by max
uh and it was in this position that ann
marie resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
you can capture the bishop
but it doesn't really do you anything
since now black gets a
queen into the game and the white is
simply much too slow to do anything
about this you can push the pawn
uh but after queen to b1 check and a few
more checks it's just gonna be it's just
gonna be a very a very easy game
uh for example king a3 are going to go
bishop to c2
threatening checkmate and the white will
never and never ever get
this uh pawn into a queen because
because of all of the threats
uh so after king to f3 and marie
resigned and a great
victory was achieved by max who also
scored his second grand master norm as
he published on twitter
he said it is great to be playing a
chess over the board again even though
it wasn't easy to get to the vergani cup
it was definitely worth it
scored my second grand master norm in
the first event and just played one of
the coolest games i have had
which the engine sometimes fails to
understand and yes those are the
greatest games those that the engines
fail to understand
now was this a good queen sacrificed uh
to start off the game with
uh i'm gonna say yes uh was it uh was it
an
absolutely correct one uh regarding the
engine maybe not
but i mean who wouldn't play this this
is just such a
such a fine natural move to play i
always say
my favorite queen sacrifice ever done
was uh ninja medina of course versus
chernik of 1962 soviet team championship
was that queen sacrifice correct uh in
those days
it was considered that it wasn't then it
was considered it was fine then again no
but now the modern engines say that uh
white is only maybe a little bit worse
and it gives you
so much uh so much to play for so i
think it was uh
definitely worth it and here of course
uh here black had
uh so much to play for and that queen
was just suffering on e1
uh for the entire game i mean this is no
no
no way to have fun playing chess uh
having your queen stuck on e1 and never
being able to move
so even though the the engines maybe uh
disagree with it
and they think okay maybe with perfect
play white could have survived this
uh i i think it was definitely worth the
shot and it was uh well worth it at
like max said he got his second grand
master norm in the event
uh so uh that's uh the game i hope you
guys uh enjoyed it as so many of you
have
requested that uh really really i i've
enjoyed it immensely i love such games
where the queen
is sacrificed very early on in the game
i would like to thank
rick malik pablo mohan marcus matthews
vika sarna and dan samarjeet for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and
i will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day